the chess drama might finally be over
Magnus Carlson Hans Neiman and chess.com
have agreed to move past what might be
the most publicly bitter conflict the
chess world has ever seen
[Music]
all right then very quick recap time in
September last year American chess
Grandmaster Hans Neiman shocked the
chess community at the singfield Cup by
beating Magnus Carlson widely regarded
as the greatest chess player of all time
Magnus announced he'd withdrawn from the
tournament via a cryptic tweet which
many took to be an implication that Hans
had cheated against him Hans admitted he
had cheated in online games when he was
12 and 16 but stated firmly that he
never cheated since especially in a
physical game of chess now Magnus never
actually provided concrete proof of how
Hans might have cheated in the
tournament and so Community speculation
went a little bit Wild One runaway
theory was that Hans had used anal beads
to receive covert signals for which
moves to make during his game vs Magnus
the feud continued in the next
tournament game when Magnus resigned in
protest after just a single move Magnus
then finally spoke out in an official
statement saying he believed pounds had
cheated more and more recently than he'd
admitted and he'd no longer be willing
to play against him chess.com who had
closed hans's account on their leading
online chess platform released their
report on him in which they argued
through statistical analysis that he had
likely cheated in over a hundred online
games but that they'd found no evidence
of him cheating in physical games such
as the Magnus game in question Hans
responded by filing a 100 million dollar
lawsuit against Magnus his chess app
company play Magnus chess.com's chief
officer Daniel wrench and streamer
Hikaru Nakamura for his comments on the
drama the 44-page lawsuit outlined how
the defendants had inflicted devastating
damages upon his reputation career and
Life by quote egregiously defaming him
and unlawfully colluding to Blacklist
him from the profession to which he has
dedicated his life in June 2023 the
lawsuit was thrown out by a Missouri
Judge who found no Merit harms his
Anti-Trust claims and dismissed his
libel and slander claim citing a lack of
jurisdiction to oversee them and we
hadn't heard much from any of the
parties involved until Monday this week
chess.com announced they'd resolved
their differences with Hans and are
moving forward in a shared statement
they said Hans have been fully
reinstated the chess.com and that they
look forward to his participation in
their events they reaffirmed that they
stand by their October 2022 report
regarding Hans including them finding no
evidence of him cheating in in-person
games next game Magnus Carlson statement
which acknowledged chess.com's report
including that there is no determinative
evidence that Hans cheated in their
Infamous game and that he is willing to
play Hans in future events finally Han
said in his statement that he's pleased
his lawsuit was resolved in a mutually
acceptable Manner and that he's
returning to chess.com I look forward to
competing against Magnus in chess rather
than in courts no matter
the obstacles that I will face
no matter how much you try to Blacklist
me no matter what you do to try and ruin
my career or slander my reputation that
these difficult times have only
strengthened my resolve and character
and have only invigorated me even more
to reach the top of Chess now some of
you might be wondering where Hikaru is
in all of this as he was one of the
people listed as a defendant in the
lawsuit Hikaru did address the article
in his own video in which he echoed the
others in their commitment to move past
the drama but also highlighted Neiman's
performances since anti-cheap measures
were brought in by chess's international
governing body feeder we of course do
know that fide has implemented new
additional security measures since the
since the events of the singfield cup of
course as far as Hans goes we do know
that Hans is currently rated about 40 to
45 points lower than he was after the
singford cup didn't did conclude in
September of 2022 again you know
whatever the reasons may be he has not
been performing at that same level so
it's over but I wouldn't call this a
happy ending one thing to note here is
magnuses and chess.com's use of the
phrase determinative evidence also known
simply as conclusive evidence by saying
they acknowledge no conclusive evidence
has been down they leave room for a
little bit of speculation and the
possibility of there being evidence only
that it's not irrefutable this has sort
of made people point to the fact that uh
the insinuations were right
that he cheated here but now that this
is happening his rating is decreasing
but he is one of the most active look
how many chess games this this Luna took
place and I say lunatic in a
complementary way okay I could never
imagine playing this much chess it's a
way of Saving Face I'm not completely
walking back their positions from last
year while still holding out an olive
branch to hands and in some ways Hans is
kind of doing a similar thing he hasn't
achieved the objectives of his lawsuit
or clear the damage to his name that's
been done by all of this but he's taking
his reinstatement on chess.com as a
victory and just hoping that in time he
won't simply be known as the guy that
Magnus accused of cheating ultimately
this is simply a public acknowledgment
that everyone involved is ready to move
past this it is not an admission of
any wrongdoing or false accusations
these carefully worded statements are
intended to preserve as much dignity as
possible for everyone involved without
having to drag this lawsuit out any
further have they all saved some face
here will the chess Community move past
all of this in the way that their
statements really do hope for only time
will tell
think more than wanting to clear his
name as a cheat he wants to clear his
name as like the anal bead guy
like I think for him that's that's more
damaging you know he's like look call me
a cheat you want but like I did not use
anal beats against magnets come on come
on Grace but you know if anything else
comes up
I'll be back for my 15th video on the
topic
I'll be right here chess man I like the
chess corresponding with the score
Esports